and welcome back to Hannity now during a
recent interview the LA director for the
center for American Islamic relations
made some outrageous remarks blaming
America watch this
let's not forget as we speak today Isis
has killed 95 percent of the victims of
Isis the Muslim themselves and let's not
forget that at the Forefront of fighting
Isis today are the brave Syrian people
who are fighting on both fronts the the
barbaric regime of Assad and the
berberism of Isis so we should give
credit when credit is due we actually
have left the Syrian people alone as
their fight and in battle with with Isis
and then we complain and say what are
the Muslim people doing to to to to root
out terrorism and extremism let's not
forget that some of our own foreign
policy As Americans as the West have
fueled that extremism when we support
cool leaders in Egypt or other places
when we support dictatorship repressive
regimes around the world that push
people over to the edge then they become
extremists then they become terrorists
we are partly responsible so this is
Terrorism is a global problem not a
Muslim problem and the solution has to
be Global everybody has a role in no
America is not partly responsible for
Terror attacks pretty unbelievable now
you may remember or keep in mind back in
2007 care was designated by the FBI as
an unindicted co-conspirator for
supporting Hamas in the case of the
United States versus The Holy Land
Foundation here with reaction author of
the complete infidel's guide to Isis
Jihad watches director Robert Spencer
the president for act for America Brigid
Gabriel and Indianapolis area Imam
Muhammad Sadiq is with us once again
Imam here we have it again
Islamic Terror Muslim terrorism
why does this keep happening
well first of all I wouldn't put it in
those terms Sean but let's say with the
name God most gracious most merciful we
offer our condolences well she pledges
she pledged her allegiance to the
Islamic State and in the wars she
pledged our allegiance to the Islamic
State the report that I heard I heard
that they decided report did you hear
what I heard I I did not hear that
report that's exactly what I heard this
is Islamic terrorism and it is Islamic
terrorism Rising all over the world and
we in America have avoided talking about
Islamic terrorism because we do not want
to offend anybody we do not want to hurt
anybody well it's time to throw
political correctness in the garbage
because right now those who are afraid
to report suspicious activities almost
have blood on their hands because the
fear crippled them from speaking the
truth and it's about time we start
speaking the truth
hang on Mom we got other people on the
show Robert Robert Spencer Robert let me
bring you into this now you have studied
Isis this is part of their Ramon they
want to radicalize they want to use the
Internet it's believed that they use the
blueprint from Al Qaeda their online
magazine to build the pipe bombs and
they were interestingly and I think in a
scary way that they were going after
these IEDs what does this mean
well what they have is a comprehensive
plan Sean to sow blood and Mayhem in the
streets of the United States they have a
very detailed guidebook for Muslims in
the United States on how they can mount
Terror attacks exactly like the one that
we saw in San Bernardino and to blend in
before they mount the attack with the
larger population they instruct them
explicitly don't carry around the Quran
don't go to mosque don't appear to be an
observant Muslim and we will call upon
you when it's time to strike what they
hope to do is to overwhelm the American
system of law enforcement and
intelligence with so many of these plots
that the system will collapse and then
they will be able to take full advantage
of that and we need to now do we need to
reevaluate Robert in the society the
cultural clash and whether or not our
immigration probably our immigration
problem our immigration laws are visa
laws do we need to now go back and
reevaluate
absolutely there needs to be a drastic
overhaul many Jihad terrorists have
gotten into the United States through
the Visa waiver program which basically
eliminates checks from 38 countries as
well as the refugee and Refugee
resettlement and Asylum programs these
have been taken advantage of by
terrorists going back to the 1993 World
Trade Center bombing when the blinds
Shake who Mastermind did that bombing
and was an asylum Seeker your reaction
to that I mean are we going to just let
Syrian refugees in when our intelligence
officials say that some may be
radicalized
Brigitte
uh no we shouldn't I mean obviously
there is no vetting system good enough
uh to let these refugees in we have to
protect ourselves we cannot let these
refugees in we do not know their
background there is no country database
that we can compare the names on it and
at this point knowing that Isis is in
the country and knowing that Isis wants
to come to the country there's no way we
can let them in and also Sean we need to
do retraining of our First Responders
and FBI agent those who were trained
that Jihad basically is Yoga uh because
remember Obama purged all our
counter-terrorism training manuals from
any reference to Jihad Islamic terrorism
all these new agencies you have to
understand exactly what we are dealing
with thank you all for being with us we
have much more on this busy news night
tonight on Hannity straight ahead